[Music] well reject Nation we have made it
to the end of what if season 2 so far pretty
great are you ready Koy to see if it sticks The
Landing if it doesn't what if it like the last
episode's awful more like worst saying in the I
don't even know if it could it's been that good
we'll see let's find out guys in the comments
let us know did you think what if season 2
stuck The Landing sure hope that response is
positive all right guys leave a like on this
video that's your first order of business
also thank you to prepper for helping us Ed
on these highlights and also a massive thank you
to everyone who became super sexy rejects that's
where you uh join us at our patreon you sync
up your own copy of what if Will through action
watch along and John and I also cover several
things exclusively over there with highlights
and watch alongs included Coy are you ready to
get into I Want To Know How It Ends let's find
out
I am Groot season 3 oh there it is sneak preview
no finale ooh one if characters now Canon that
is dope love that yes all of this reac oneing
it's all what iing look at them all oh I don't
even recall some of that I don't think some of
this has happened yet and know might season one
stuff that is great I love this yet Marvel barely
promoted the show please talk about this Marvel
now all that effort London 16002 we're back a
world at peace thanks to a hero from an entirely
different Universe Captain Peggy Carter a warrior
out of her own time hot too by the looks of things
this happy hour could use a little more happiness
being single malt few centuries ahead of schedule
of course he really is supreme any chance you can
offer me a lift home I'd call a taxi but I left
my purse in another dimension come on Peggy step
into my office theirs was the bond of two Heroes
for nice reference for like Captain Carter Dr
Steven strange had been on a difficult journey of
his own in his pursuit to save Christine Palmer he
destroyed his soul the one phenomenal episode but
it was only as the world collapsed around him that
he saw the error of his ways two legends must band
together to face a threat oh they're going to be
the leaders of this one but against whom welcome
to my humble abode the sanctum infinum oh okay
upgraded you've been here all alone well not quite
I've been kind of busy with whom Infinity Ultron
I think you know and Thanos Loki beings of Untold
power help them on destroying their universes
what the hell it's slow down show but look there
is actually something I need your help with uh
strange I'd rather go home some Guardian you were
it's actually it's a bit embarrassing to be honest
one of them's escaped how did you know Gremlins
aliens Jurassic Park I can already hear the
Watcher in toning that meddling in the Multiverse
always a mistake I know he's a fifth dimensional
being with that big head and that soothing voice
that doesn't always make him right I love how the
Cape is so big it still casts him into like his
big Shadow his own shadow big Shadow on his face
so I I love how Haley's playing her here but I
still want to see that weakness our bad guy is a
she Captain Carter who I lost her Trail here in
the South Dakota Badlands well kori's a bad guy
to him maybe cuz the power why can't you just do
this because you my friend are an unknown and here
ah thank you this will work out pretty well Peggy
you you'll go find her I don't trust him don't
trust trust him is the issue yeah exactly then
I'll be able to bring you both back here and then
I'm out no no no I don't trust her how will I know
it's her oh trust me you'll know that's a little
worrying he's behaving strange so strangely so
strangely Dr more like doctor strangely yeah more
like Dr what Dr suspicious he writes the he writes
the comments I I'm an aspiring writer I don't know
if you know that do suspicious over here skull
Rush cool you here to help for a change or just to
narate the bomb at project rebirth packed a bigger
bang in this universe I love the mood intention
of this neither you nor Steve Rogers survived
Hydra unleashed the Tess's Powers won the war and
destroyed the world oh damn this is a terrible
world heavy I get involved you watch it's about
seeing great well strange found a way to watch
and see he's getting involved making a difference
I like how this season basically became that hope
for Captain America to go to all the times and
do like things this is what Captain Carter is
yeah it's true like all the gems are Cur helping
multiverses and look how good the snow looks this
so pretty this looks like old school horror
Disney it is kahori but she's not bad I mean
to some if you insist on ending this in a fight
you will regret yeah very good that was a good
one is strangers on Red Skull side I don't think
you'd be teamed up with skull got damn impeccable
timing let me guess he asked you
to help him save the Multiverse
to save it from you why'd you
ask I'm not a universe killer he
is he's watching right now yep my name
is gordi and I think Gori I thought it
was kahori there's a D in there must
be that delusional or honored us is
lying to you first time we've heard
her speak English I just realized oh
no God damn it strange nice work finding her for
me he wants to extract her power did he tell you
about the forge just targeting Universe Killers
he's Gathering righteous Heroes too well for what
he's feeding everyone to the forge enough why
what are you doing strange he's driven himself
mad no strange isn't trying to save universes
he's trying to resurrect his Universe oh God
damn it Steven you're trying to bring back
Christine aren't you yes I am and if anyone
could understand it's you my god dude I thought
we were passed this but this is madness a come
on Peggy a Multiverse of Madness you know
you do the same thing for Steve Peggy it's
pegy I would never do this for
Steve dude not cool bro not love Steve
Rogers wouldn't want me to the cost is
tooo high in the grand scheme of things
it's a small price to pay what the hell
man trust me Peggy it's better
this way he hasn't gone full
[Music] evil oh my God oh
my God oh my God what are
we going to get let people out let let them free
oh [__] awesome universes even the
dragons here well that should keep him
busy I lovex and references like the in
The Cabin in the Woods there's just so
much hang on [Music] tight they're
not doing anything they so generic
oh no it is his cabin at the W
what the hell it really is who
whoa I love this so much starting a prison
riot of universe Killers not my best idea we
got to go done Slinger [Music] Loki the amount of
work people are doing over the holiday break to
break down those scenes I know we just going
to go pretty we're just going nice nice like
nice oh oh it's zombie Wanda's back is this
how we Greenlight the Marvel zombie show W
Damie Z careful yeah I know zombies are pretty
[Music] Universal oh great here
we go oh you got this this not a
problem red versus blue red versus [Applause]
blue they're trying to eat the
[Applause]
shoe these Circle tracking they just
the the cinematography again oh my
God what's happening who's doing
this Loki what did you do it's
not Meen zombies sounds like my goddess of
death now KN yes the last woman to demand
that of me regretted it oh darling I'm No
Ordinary woman I'm the goddess of [Music]
death I am oh you CL BR I love how crazy
this is It's just leveling up I am as
good and this is all proving
a watchu right by the way yeah
no like if you're going to do this plot you
want to just go like ape [__] with how big
can it get yeah it's strange he's coming
leave them to the warden let's go yeah man
the structur to this is genius oh that was so
cool redo with The Advengers Infinity War yes
at that moment he's a [__] Thanos is a
[__] in the one of series is a [__]
he's out the one consistent thing three
episodes for three that's just season
two oh oh [__] with the infinity oh
the one for season one we'll need that
Infinity that's right the s a chance against
strange Infinity Monger forgot about that
Cliffhanger who is she it's a little too powerful
sometimes the what Earthly power is that I don't
know what she is it's just a tesseract I guess
teleportation [Music] is I guess not the ultimate
power I shouldn't D strength him yeah just got
him out of the suit yeah which deprived him of the
powers cool [Music]
no oh my God what is happening right now she
was already so ultimate these two ultimate ass
chicks fits like a glove does fit like a glove
fits like a nice nice sports bra too Captain
Gauntlet strange just started the forge we have
to stop him now before he feeds the prisoners
to it in my opinion not overpowered no just
what do you mean Infinity Carter just powered
enough Infinity Carter is doing just fine both
both of them together what if there's two Super
Saiyan women how do we destroy it well I'd
rather you didn't you changed your outfit
pretty cool but you might remember I defeated
that armor once before even the music's coming
back and he's
dead oh come on I thought you were
just warming up get a little of
this what a fun hodge podge of
[__] yeah guess you figured that
armor out what a crazy missley
you think you're building up to some
culmination of a heroic battle together
yeah
no leave it alone you're making it
unstable shouldn't have asked Peggy to do
this does she know how to use all
the stones already it would seem
okay it's like the secret Invasion finale
very much just still at all the powers at
once you've lived in solitude far too long
strange youve forgotten there are more of
us than there are of you that's the thing oh
what there aren't oh let's do this that's a
great idea I just love how it keeps leveling up
oh my God it doesn't stop I love it so much I H
okay all jokes aside having to blast this this
is a melee an absurd melee this is so absurd
let's go strange do some strange [__] come on
look how beautiful of a shot that it's Captain
C always the soldier out of time it doesn't have
to end this way don't get me wrong guys there are
some narrative flaws with this episode but there's
so much fun that's happening that it's making up
for
it was like when um strange fought
Thanos in a way yeah yeah butterflies
all all this to make one super soldier oh my God
we're suddenly taking a big slowdown moment Steve
is this real what of course it is the Nazis are on
the march across Europe we need to even the odds
seems so small in comparison to what's going on
with the Multiverse yeah you know it's going back
to urin just Nazis stay we'll finish the fight
we'll win the war you and me Peg we can finally be
together but if you change this point in time the
butterfly effect and the butterflies yeah I don't
get it it's does it mean a subtle metaphor Greg
I'll explain it after I wish that were true but
you you're not him is this
trying to get her to give up
yeah huh huh she has strength
and speed see what you've
chosen oh no he's begun he's beating them to
the forge I just wish the motivation of Strang
is rooted in something else isolation Madness
yeah I mean she's just redoing the same [__]
he was doing last time yeah the same same
motivation the protection around the forge
is weakening I can it's back peddling to me it
is to episode eight of last season yeah like I
don't mind him being like dark and Sinister but
uh I just wish it wasn't this like bring for Ste
back yeah the exact same whoa but man there's
some really fun [__] happening right before
my eyes right now look how beautifully animated
this is and all these characters we've met and
experienced neat trick but you see I mastered
that one a long time ago it's just a game of
tops it's a lot of toys smashing [Music] together
my world must be reborn or countless others will
die uh what when was that explained oh he snapped
re Choice Peggy Carter they will feed my machine
that is so monstrous just feeding Heroes to the
machine just lives and you my friend are finished
not entirely oh another power up girls get it done
give him give him hell men help look they're still
being Heroes as are falling to their deaths the
10 Rings me oh this is cool all the weapons coming
together Legendary Weapons that's cool as they're
fly to their death they're giving up their weapons
one final fight beautiful what happened to all
the strangers she butter fly them away that's
right there's so much happening I
forget what do you mean it's been very
[Music]
linear
what is happening right now this is insanity just
keep going show more things more keeping keep it
going just your tumble weed man look at look at
what she looks like what this [__] is going
[Music] [Applause] [Music] on it's just a fun
infinite helic Carter this is a snowball effect
of epic proportions look at this [__] he has M
and the 10 rings in offense and defense W he's a
vampire with horns oh he's becoming the thing
he feared oh he's that thing from episode four
he's already that thing whoa it's already in yeah
yeah yeah it's just unveiling it right nothing is
ever over strange if you're in there you need
to listen to me no you will listen I I want to
compare to to the secret Invasion finale but I'll
I I got to tell you why this is so much better
afterwards oh it's better but it has problems
similar no but this strange this isn't you it is
me smiley
face my
God
the bog all right she's lost all the buildups I
love how it's like a real game of tops though yeah
of how whenever you think it's over the the other
opponents got one more up their sleeve pgy so it
just culminates in this crazy cacophony of [__]
whoa that lookes [Music] down smash into his
mouth or his nose whatever that body part
is kind of looks like Mr Sinister did you punch
the evil out of him it's all it takes it's like
Amnesia it's going to explode come on
strange there has to be a way to stop
it I can't my grief is too strong Christine
wouldn't want this but we do oh this grief is
manifested into a completely separate being yeah
I always thought that it was just an extension
of him but it's like their character is
grief yeah like the Shadow Self is this
demon so I guess it didn't completely undo his
Arc [Music]
strange I don't know now I'm kind of on that
path of like I was saying I wish there was the
different motivation but he was he don't get
over something it's true just gets bigger that
is true though he was obsessed and he didn't
seem to get over it at the end it just felt
repetitive in the moment I take it this means I'm
not dead no and neither is cordi I sent her back
to her home universe that maliciousness didn't go
away in that episode yeah yeah but in the moment
of introduction sure it's like well we've had
this yeah but like villains have motivation that
repeats itself because that's their motivation
like yeah it's true that's Christine strangest
F worked yes but at the cost of his life he
recreated this universe but was never born into it
and never will be that is tragic you saw it didn't
you the forge kahori the monster in strange oh he
didn't just see it he watched it we nearly lost
everything but we didn't the Multiverse didn't
need me to intervene Peggy it just needed you this
is just Peggy show yeah this was her through line
season right like there was nobody needs some
struggle though got not going lie it's the one
part of season 2 has been a little bit hard for
me it's like I I really I like her a lot that I
don't love her because I feel like there's a lack
of struggle perhaps we could take the scenic route
home surely there's something worth seeing along
the way just you watch season three for bad I do
oh my God what yes are they going to go into the
they're actually going to be connecting it now I
mean that's the same tree of life that's the same
of life right dude I still I still look man I can
logically see some [__] but I'm not I'm not
going to lie and I would not lie to you guys I
would not lie to you guys I totally think you
guys should buy a shirt from real reject store
reation shop.com you got it and I'm just going to
say it while we wait for a postcard scene that we
got a shirt like our Pedro Pascal one last got a
recently Doctor Who shirts full of a whole bunch
of Doctor Who quotes on the Tardis uh we got space
babies of the Galaxy we got a billion of them and
it is one of the absolute best ways to support the
channel Co apparently owns a bunch and they're all
living in his closet like they good somebody puts
his clothes away and then I had a charity event
today so you're giving me ex about helping people
go home between I came wear you can't wear a real
reject shirt that's Christmas I wore a Christmas
sweater here I am I know I know post credit scene
you we wait for post credit scene before we
review and I'll say this all I want to say is
while I recognize some narrative flaws I think
there's to review there's so much things in here
that I'm just not going to go into the details yet
there's so much things in here that while I can
compare it to other things that did why it didn't
work of what I liked it I I had so much fun with
this I I genuinely was like this was a blast I I I
kind of wouldn't have it any other way except for
20 minutes longer just to flesh out I would like
the few more episodes to be 5 minutes long youie
Jesus Christ not what going tradition and how it's
done everyone knows great great soundtrack just wa
enjoying the score just wait waiting look at all
these talented people ADR done and Burbank just
get to the post credit scene who gives a [__]
Gordon just get to the post credit special thanks
Roy Thomas great great writer honestly I don't
need a post credit soon we just got to wait to
see if got assume if it doesn't have it if not we
write we take a baseball bat to Kevin F Here Comes
Deadpool Deadpool Stream post credits it's the
next thing no Echo it's not going to have post
credits I think there's going to be a post I don't
think it's post that's a good thing we waited to
review or maybe maybe Disney was like Hey not in
the Press we're going to give you screeners we're
not going to give a post credits what if they do
what Sony did that one time and it's just across
the spider versus the end of Venom and they're
just like here's an echo scene I I I would be
fine with that I mean I think it might happen in
one week all at once five episodes of echo uh can
we review now fine all right uh I would say of the
post endgame shows and movies which includes phase
four and the phase five up into this point this
give it to me blun Koy this makes the top third
there's been like 10 properties and this makes
top third I did not like the finale as much as
the rest of the season but I did not dislike
the finale as much as I disliked a lot of what
season one so therefore it is much higher than
like my whole what if experience and I really
liked what most of it was uh 1602 I could have
been a finale for me um I I feel like they could
have had strange across multiple seasons and just
be like a tease I would have been okay with cuz
602 felt like a big culmination Avengers event I
didn't necessarily need the the the culmination
of like ah but it was fun it just felt a little
bit like the secret Invasion problem where it's
like this girl you just met plus Captain Carter
who doesn't have weak have more and that became a
bit much but overall um it was worth the fun which
I think was what you kept saying is like the joy
I had far outweighed my brain going like bit much
because they just kept leveling up the cacophony
of excitement and I love seeing characters that
I could imagine how that what if character came
to be I love the idea of pausing and finding new
things I love the rapid comic esque stack on stack
on stack that I think Secret Wars is going to feel
like worth the the squeeze but once I slowed down
to think I was like I don't know about that uh
dude yeah I I cannot disagree with you I can
but I cannot ah you could hence the duplicitous
The Duality of Greg the dichotomy of thought the
duplicitous nature of being yeah well okay like
with the Marvels that was an experience for me
where I was like I see the narrative's problems
and I can see how people have fun with this
personally the problems are so outweighing the
fun for me this is the inverse and for me that's
yeah that's a really good point about exactly
how I'd put it is because visually it still
popped visually it was still exciting to look at
and joy came out of me let's let's really quickly
get the secret Invasion comparon out of the way I
cannot tell you what the game of tops was in that
game between grav Vic and and uh oh my God what
is her name Amelia Clark what oh my God what is
her name uh memorable show that is a really bad
sign for us as wait for the show or for the show
because they didn't make us care about her her
name is something talis's daughter yeah that's
sh is a name gravic versus talis's that's better
this is gonna bug me um Sarah I can't no Linda
be what's her name anyway secret Invasion with
Sarah versus gravic what is her [__] name was
not a good character man just such a waste anyway
yeah um yeah that that was just like let's just
give them a bunch of powers and then just make
it up as we're going along in the visual effects
Department right that's how it felt mhm here there
was at least as crazy as it was the Rhythm was
there was it they had to structure it out and they
had to map it out and they had to at least like
have a drawing board I I don't just mean like an
actual like because they animated it they had to
at least have like a list of things and go how
would this what would be the one to stack next
what would be the one to stack next they had to at
least have a structure to it so as much as it was
like batshit insane there was at least an actual
game of tops and the the commitment to how crazy
it just kept going from Once Peggy broke open all
the all all the prisons yeah once Cabin in the
Woods started once Cabin in the Woods started
it did not let go I loved just how Relentless
it became because if it it at least embraced the
relentlessness that's what I'll say if it didn't
have that part of its soul that I cuz you're
either going to have ass it or you're not going
to meet it all the way and if and if if if the
fact that they met it all the way is I thought was
the Saving Grace for something that was like yeah
these two girls way too overpowered this two thing
right here this was strange kind of comes out of
nowhere and when you think about it because the
buildup to it wasn't felt for this season it was
in last season which was years ago and I did like
that it in the in the Avengers you gather a team
and they had the team already gathered in each
episode so I like that the weapons are gathered
throughout the season like a Dungeons dragons
campaign like I like that you got a weapons
Origins that way when it all came together it was
about the items and that allowed the overpowering
to at least have some narrative structure like
you're describing with the blueprint like you
have all that so at least it felt like oh they
were planning it from the beginning not like okay
we've reached the finale what the [__] like it
felt like a journey then the killmonger tease from
season one Cliffhanger even though it soled in s
seconds like that's what I mean there's just so
much but that's part of the problem I do have is
they were like oh exactly I'm like you guys set up
something and then you're like what if this op Duo
well I in season one they don't tease with strange
being back going back to the villainous route no
but I mean they kind of allude to the idea that
he's still evil underneath I felt that it ended
with like I don't trust him well I think for this
particular season of how they've built in strange
he looks like Jafar the way they don't trust that
guy well the way they're building him up with his
little appearances here so there's something
contextually that I'm like oh I kind of like
the idea of like it's a mislead like you think
he's building up to assemble towards a greater
threat but it's not actually he the greater threat
yeah he's the greater thre but that also ties into
him killing people in this Kil like that worked
for me yeah yeah yeah yeah like there's there's
stuff contextually like about it and I found
my way back to I I could see why narratively
he of course he wouldn't be over this Christine
thing but I thought as a character he had like
kind I buy I I buy like forever Doctor Strange is
being like Christine okay like forever like that's
just like who he's going to and he would do this
Choice 100% okay all right so that how arrogant
egotistical Doctor Strange is he would assume he
would find a way weirdly narratively that was the
part of it I I just wish it was somewhat of a
my problem was like if Captain America or Thor
were the character that suddenly had all those
Powers at the end of a thing people be like and
then they have a new character we just met plus a
character we haven't had a lot of time to invest
it and being like it it just felt oh totally so I
didn't mind the doctor strange as much as I minded
the like what power don't you have battle which
could work with Doctor Strange in a version but
not with like how did she learn how to do the
infinity stuff like when did that happen and
like those things definitely bothered me enough
but not enough to throw me out I was still like
shiny like I like we said the inverse of secret
Invasion where it's like I'm having more joy than
my brain is overthinking yeah the shiny was tasty
enough that I was not like ooh bitter like I was
in like yay yeah the cotton candy was good yeah
I and I'm not just being forgiving like I I will
level with you we had a cynical year we'll level
with you when we hate like I really don't give a
[__] no I mean we've been very open about all
of our like recent disappointments CU yeah this
is there this there's so many narrative problems
with this and you might even completely be in the
comments disagreeing with what we're saying are
narrative problems that's totally fine I still
had a great time this was still a lot of fun so
John got out of nowhere a couple months ago John
was just going sure sure sure he he was not doing
that it just always stood out to me and I'm like I
think you got it from you that's an expression
I do I also doing it for years yeah I started
doing it in Rocky Horror like five years back
the origins of my sure well I also that's when
I started saying tight tight tight tight tight
I remember like two of my catr no cuz a kid that
was doing the play with me started doing it for
Brooklyn 99 I it up from him and then I saw a
clip of Brooklyn 99 I was like that Thief but I I
stole it from him he does yeah yeah so he does ti
ti ti I was like clever but yeah I sometimes have
little roots of my like Expressions that I tie to
memories to events and like sure was like back in
the Rocky era fun fact this is for the patrons no
this isn't the YouTube video man but uh yeah I I
definitely feel like there were enough issues to
mention them but not enough issues to have it be a
a negative like it bothered me but the episode was
still a blast if that makes sense like it's not
as good as the rest for me it would sorry sorry
to interrupt I I just know I just know forget KY
promise I'm sorry I just know forget it would it
would be more um bothersome if this show wasn't
only semi serialized you know what I mean like
these other shows we're talking about where
the when the finale drops the bomb narratively
is because that's a serialized show yeah this is
only semi serialized at the end of the day they're
all even the serialized ones are meant to be in
mythology of some kind like the continuation of
Peggy Carter story of the different places she's
hopp in between while she's been a through line
and inconsistency it's still an anthology episode
and because of that I'm not like you ruin this
you know yeah I agree and and I do think that
I'm okay enough with like I think it's more
exciting for me to watch five to seven movies
get to the point where Cap wields me only then
it is for me to get to the end of a series where
every weapon we've discovered is all all beaten
used by one character I'd rather it be a slowburn
one buildup but if you're gonna do it committing
to it like you were describing this is the best
version of that they could have done and that's
why I think it's not quite secret Invasion but
it is something where I would have rathered it
ended smaller or even ended with 1602 and then
go to season 3 with Doctor Strange buildup then
it does it does lower this season from like
it was an a to a minus for me now it's like
a nice solid a minus it does it does affect my
experience okay yeah man I'm right uh I'll let
you have that yeah it's not I mean an A minus is
still great it's four stars out of five like this
was a very enjoyable experience but um yeah that
did bother me a little bit my main issue with with
P like Peggy's an enjoyable character to watch
she's enjoyable to watch my main issue is again
I keep bringing this up the struggle man like
like sure okay in the game of tops is she like
having a technical struggle with beating strange
yes it's more of just like the nothing seems to
really wear and tear at her you know she doesn't
really seem to get exhausted she doesn't really
seem to get the reason I can do this all day is
exciting is because cuz he's cuz he's struggling
to keep going yeah and the reason is because he's
like I will do this exactly that's what makes a
great fight that's what makes that's why you root
for John Wick it's why Mission Impossible wasn't
as fun for us because Tom Cruz was going through
a CGI landscape and didn't have any that's why ad
Mission Impossible three the finale is exciting
cuz he's like I got to bomb in my head and I got
to keep going and I'm running like crazy through
all these is playing be as good as anyone ever
has it's really yeah that's but we had the same
problems with mission impossible as we do with
this I think and uh yeah it's it's exactly my
problems with dead reckoning my problems with
Peggy both starring Haley Atwell Haley atwell's
dead reckoning and Haley atwell's what if season
two similar parallel issue you know in the
Multiverse of Tom Cruz the haly Atwell problem
really reflects itself in Doctor Strange battles
um has been a counter batch ever worked with Tom
Cruz they should they should that would be fun um
yeah man like no you're you're it's and I guess
because I've been at that point with pegy that
I'm just like screw it just give her everything
at this point like she doesn't really seem that
exhausted so just give her like why is her super
soldier so much more powerful it's Al my question
too with like I love the episode with I guess we'
getting her name wrong this whole time we we spent
a long time remember she added a little D in there
CI Cort but it might be like a an accent thing
like for like her R we hadn't heard her speak
English and then it sounded like it was another
letter in there she's been speaking English this
whole time what have I been ra your racist mind
I just heard I can't understand out I'm like what
is she saying speak Indian sorry back you know
I don't speak Spanish guys this is what happens
when you film Nine episodes just chaos but wor
the episode um uh I don't remember we earned
chaos of episode 9 by filming this all as a binge
I have no idea what we were talking about uh dead
reckoning something there yeah I enjoyed it
but I definitely want Marvel to slow down on
their overpowering characters my question is
yeah with cohort like I don't know what she
is and why she is tesseract like like she she is
in a day and age where you know like I think the
sad fact is here's the sad reality Co and I are
obviously the last crowd to be part of the like
[__] culture mentality right the sad reality
is though when you when you suddenly go when you
like keep introducing female characters and you
keep overpowering them with little to no effort
and then narratively you don't know what to
do with them so you take Captain Marvel out
of the picture because she's too powerful I'm like
you're not helping this argument this narrative is
only fueling itself Mery soothing that people keep
pointing out you're not helping it when when I'm
like but as a character like the Hardy character
like I really liked her I was emotionally invested
when I thought canning killed her I was like
oh my God no way like I really feared for her
so I'm invested in her I but but then the other
side of it's like why is she so goddamn powerful
and then can't she do Captain Carter too like
cap earning like you brought Milner that when
he picked it up I if he's worthy he earned it
and Peggy here is just like I'm just a magnet
of powers you know and the Mard is also a payoff
for the Age of Ultron tease maybe and this didn't
there was no time to tease and she's been the
only serialized thing yeah and I enjoyed the
Weaponry getting their little Origins that was
clever but I do feel like there was no moment
of her learning how to wield the the there's
no struggle there's no struggle like I enjoy
watching them I'm not I do enjoy watching
them but there is that part of me that steps
back and goes why are you so goddamn powerful
and I get when you say Mary Su you think Star
Wars and then you think Luke Skywalker learned
pretty quick too I think what people say all the
time on how it's a lot of the time incorrectly
applied 100% And then but I'm acknowledging that
male characters have that problem too absolutely
especially in comics but I just saw Percy Jackson
in the Olympians with the movie I was like this
Percy Jackson's Mar this guy this Gary Su just
learned a lot totally Mar but I do think that
we we have had a lot of female characters uh
have not given the time to breathe as they should
have I think it's more of a writing issue than it
being a woman issue I think it's like okay we've
got these new characters and go and it's like
no no give them time like let them flourish I'm
pretty sure Kathleen Kennedy kicked in the door
on Marvel she was like said you make woman Ray
yeah woman Ray we lost Daisy Ridley make every
woman Ray I love Ray Ray she's back I do love Ray
back maybe that's my unpopular opinion but I love
Ray I think she's great yeah I think Bill burd's
the best character in Star Wars since Empire man
Mandalorian Bill burp Planet Boston is the best
place in the Galaxy oh yeah totally that character
is so good that's the Stormtrooper sag I wanted
from Finn Mayfield Mayweather Mayfield Mayfield
I think it's Mayfield yeah Mayweather's a boxer
but I think Mayfield is the arc we wanted from
Finn Mayweather could be a character day could
be a character and Skywalker Mayweather a lot
of weather sensibilities a lot of Sky elements my
point being I want a character whether it's Storm
Trooper like Bill bur or if it's a character like
Captain oh you're right Emperor Imperial officer
right like he yeah oh [__] you remembered
something yeah down I'm ready no I'm not uh
but whether it's the character that we assume
is 2D it's more exciting to see a character we
assume is 2D become three dimensional Allah
Bill bur Imperial officer getting that like
time to shine than it is to see a character get
more and more powerful and then never have a
moment to waiver and I don't feel like that's
the one thing about this season I do wish we
had was a little bit more moment of failure w ing
second thought like as soon as you Dr sh was bad
there was like a pause okay I'm going to take out
Doctor Strange there was not a there was I just I
wanted that from the character and I think it is
fueling the certain YouTube channels that Pride
themselves on hate yeah it's true it's just it
just puts Marvel in a bad position oh God if we
could just become one of those channels money we'
make oh man we'd be so rich I just don't yeah like
it'd be twice as profitable maybe three times but
at what cost internally one bad comment away from
these damn Libs turning against us where I just
need to cancel culture I just need to join the
other side yeah over there waiting right there
got pitchforks their pointy white hats I've my
eyes have been opened opened I don't get woke
get open whatever that works for what is their
Awakening called thing know I don't know the
the well the blackening is a movie where the
racist inning not all racist get sleep you know
sometimes I watch some of these videos of these
people and sometimes I feel like they actually
have a good point and then other times And So It
Begins there's a couple points amongst a lot of
bad points that's the problem is every so often
I'll hear like two good points out of 20 I'm like
I think what you hate is so much is the is the is
the um the presentation it's think of it like this
on a completely different flip side people a lot
of people hate reaction videos they'll hate our
videos cuz they'll see our thumbnail and assume
they're all the same video is that yeah and then
they watch the video like oh there's actually a
lot more discussion moment yeah but they always
look like they're shocked or there's actually a
lot more nuance and discussion oh they actually
didn't even like this you know and so a lot of
times it's often judged and I think some people
hate that presentation granted our presentation
is not negative most of the time most of the time
yeah and I think what you don't like the most is
the negative presentation right right even if
there's a positive idea yeah cuz I think some
Sometimes some of these people I won't say who
uh some one in particular who I was like let me
Venture into this person's videos and I was like
oh boy these are really well-made videos and I'm
like with the presentation will always lump them
into the certain camp that you were talking about
where sometimes those people who present also Fain
in their videos hate and the same and they're outo
but they're profiting off the hate yeah yeah so
I think which is more Shilling in a different
way but sometimes yeah which is heroically dark
Shilling they're Shilling to their Market not the
studio I hope I made my point clear without name
dropping anyone specific but I think I understand
but it's like evil chilling is still just as big
a problem when you're trying to Plate an angry
mob you're still doing a thing where it's being
an authentic but sometimes there is a a Nuance
that I think can gets lost in the anyway doesn't
matter I'm saying a broken clock's right twice a
day sometimes you say enough [__] you got some
wisdom in there but if you're [__] 10 out of 12
clock [__] I'm saying sometimes you got to
open the video koi and go wait a minute this
is actually a good video but you won't give it a
shot I don't like YouTube called very much I yeah
who the [__] does that's what I'm saying why
would I why would I spend time going oh suffer
it's it's the worst I don't like it but I I like
connecting with people that consume positive
content on YouTube but that feels like it's a
dying art on YouTube because because what we're
talking about like we just both admitted how much
more money would be so it's hard to be like yeah
YouTube but it's like the one good thing which
is intelligent discourse is the thing that's less
popular well dude no it's time to start hating on
everything I mean I've learned to post on Twitter
and just do it the three dots and go mute and walk
away now I literally I mute every thread because
I know the more controversial the better it'll
do and the less I'll want to be involved so it's
the worst to be like let me use this platform
of evil I know that feel so it's like I don't
want YouTube to become that I feel like it is yeah
well but while we're here check out shirts at nerd
rot.com nerd Riot that's a different website
I know no reation shirts.com I uh no reation
shop no one here remembers the name of the store
reject Nation Oh yeah is re ation shop.com I can
picture the logo now yeah reation what do you
think of the finale they let you down did you
love it do you watch ntic videos you made it the
whole time you said nerd Riot you just said nerd
rtic yeah yeah yeah oh [__] I'm like we did such
a good job hey man you know uh your boy blocked me
on Twitter I went to go see what Tyrone was about
and he like [__] I preemptively blocked me like
guess I won't learn he preemptively blocked you
did you call him out earlier we mentioned him in
one of your one of our lives and I was like yeah
I hear that guys and I was like oh but he just
like block me all [__] I was like I guess
I'll never learn it's okay it's right it was
funny he was crying about some like not going to
Disneyland he was too woke and I like went to go
like look at the video to see if it was actually
I was trying to give him a chance and then I was
like I guess I can't that's about what it's about
what the video is I literally was trying to do
what you just described where you were like I'm
going to give this a chance and see if there's
new on and I I clicked I was like I will not be
this about it's a funny video I couldn't watch
Internet it's a lovely Place have a good
[__] holiday uh it is New Year's in a
couple days may your New Year be merry gay
and bright this is for the sink Happy New
[Music] Year